.
BUT FOR NOW, THANKING YOU ALL.
>>> MEANWHILE, PRESIDENT BIDEN
SAID TODAY HE IS BEING
CONSTANTLY BRIEFED ON
CONGRESSIONAL NEGOTIATIONS TO
PASS GUN REFORM AND HE WILL DO
WHAT HE CAN TO BRING ABOUT,
QUOTE, REAL PROGRESS.
HE GAVE A PRIME TIME ADDRESS TO
PUT PRESSURE ON REPUBLICANS TO,
QUOTE, DO SOMETHING ABOUT THE
GUN VIOLENCE EPIDEMIC IN
AMERICA.
>> THE PRESIDENT PROPOSED A BAN
ON ASSAULT WEAPONS OR RAISING
THE AGE TO BUY ONE TO 21.
HIS FRUSTRATION WAS ON DISPLAY
AS TALKS, AGAIN, APPEAR TO BE ON
A ROAD TO NOWHERE.
>> MY GOD, THE FACT THAT THE
MAJORITY OF THE SENATE
REPUBLICANS DON'T WANT ANY OF
THESE PROPOSALS EVEN TO BE
DEBATED OR COME UP FOR A VOTE, I
FIND UNCONSCIONABLE.
WE CAN'T FAIL THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AGAIN.
>> UNSURPRISINGLY, REPUBLICANS
ARE PUSHING BACK.
>> WHAT'S WRONG WITH RAISING THE
AGE FOR SEMIAUTOMATIC WEAPONS?
>> IT'S UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
>> WE HAVE GUESTS TO TALK ABOUT
THIS ISSUE, THE FORMER MEMBER OF
THE TEXAS HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, WHICH HAS
WRITTEN AN OP-ED IN WHICH HE
ACCUSES REPUBLICANS OF BEING
FECKLESS.
LET'S START THERE.
WHY THE COWARDESS IN TEXAS TO DO
ANYTHING?
>> IT'S DIFFICULT AS AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL TO DEFY THE NRA AND THE
PARTY WHEN IT COMES TO THESE
KINDS OF INITIATIVES.
AS A MEMBER OF THE TEXAS
LEGISLATURE, I'VE TRIED ON A
NUMBER OF OCCASIONS TO INTRODUCE
AND SUPPORT COMMON SENSE GUN
REFORM, THINGS LIKE WHAT THE
PRESIDENT TALKED ABOUT LAST
NIGHT.
RAISE THE AGE TO 21, PROVIDE
BACKGROUND CHECKS, EVEN
LICENSING.
IN TEXAS, DURING THE TIME THAT I
WAS THERE, WITHOUT ANY
RESTRICTIONS WHATSOEVER, PEOPLE
COULD ACCESS HIGH POWERED
WEAPONRY.
WHEN I DEFIED THAT, WENT AGAINST
THAT, THE EFFECT WAS IMMEDIATE,
NOT ONLY FROM MY OWN PARTY, BUT
FROM THE NRA AND FROM VARIOUS
GUN LOBBYISTS.
SO IMMEDIATELY I'M ATTACKED,
IMMEDIATELY MONEY FLOWS INTO THE
COFFERS OF PEOPLE THAT WOULD
OPPOSE ME IN A PRIMARY AND I WAS
DRUMMED OUT OF THE PARTY FOR
THIS KIND OF TRANSGRESSION.
SO WHILE I RECOGNIZE THAT THESE
KINDS OF INITIATIVES MAKE SENSE
TO MOST PEOPLE WHO ARE WATCHING
TODAY, IF YOU'RE AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL IN A RED STATE AND YOU
DEFY THE NRA OR YOUR LOCAL
ASSOCIATION, IT WILL BE VERY
DIFFICULT IN AN ELECTION CYCLE
FOR YOU.
>> REYNA, CONSIDERING WHAT JASON
SAID AND WROTE AS CONTEXT, WHAT
DO YOU MAKE OF THIS REQUEST, NOT
AN ORDER FROM GOVERNOR ABBOTT,
BUT THIS REQUEST FROM THE
LEGISLATION FOR A SPECIAL
SESSION TO MEET ON SCHOOL
SAFETY, MENTAL HEALTH, SOCIAL
MEDIA, POLICE TRAINING AND
FIREARMS SAFETY?
DO YOU THINK THAT'S JUST FOR
SHOW?
>> WELL, THIS IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY MOMENT AND I'VE
WORKED IN GOVERNMENT AND
POLITICS FOR NEARLY TWO DECADES.
BUT BEFORE ALL OF THAT I'M AN
AMERICAN MOM AND I CAN SAY THIS,
THAT JUST LIKE WHAT HAPPENS IN
STATE LEGISLATORS, THERE HAS
BEEN GOOD NEWS IN PLACES LIKE
FLORIDA.
OUR FEDERAL LAWMAKERS REFUSE TO
ACT AND TAKE ON CERTAIN REFORMS
THAT DON'T IN FRINGE ON PERSONAL
LIBERTIES IN A WAY IN WHICH
RIGHT WING MEDIA IS MAKING IT
OUT TO SEEM.
THERE IS NO LARGE CONSPIRACY FOR
DEMOCRATS TO TAKE AWAY YOUR
STUFF.
WE NEED TO PUSH BACK ON THAT
RHETORIC.
THERE ARE REASONABLE REPUBLICANS
LIKE ME ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
COAST TO COAST, WHO HAVE FELT
HOW HORRIFIC THIS GUN VIOLENCE
HAS PERMEATED OUR DAILY LIVES
AND WE NO LONGER WILL STAY
SILENT.
WE KNOW THERE'S SOME ACTION THAT
OUR FEDERAL LAWMAKERS CAN TAKE,
BUT IT'S TIME FOR THEM TO STAND
UP FOR REASONABLE, PRACTICAL
REFORMS THAT SO MANY REPUBLICANS
AROUND THE COUNTRY SUPPORT.
>> JASON, IT'S REALLY
INTERESTING TO HEAR YOUR
EXPERIENCE OF BEING IN THE TEXAS
STATE LEGISLATURE AND THEN BEING
DRUMMED OUT, AS YOU SAY, OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND BEING
DEPRIVED MONEY AND THAT
FULL-COURT PRESS AGAINST YOU FOR
TRYING TO PROPOSAL COMMON SENSE.
WHY ARE REPUBLICANS SO AFRAID OR
BEHOLDEN, LET ME SAY, OF THE
NRA?
>> THE NRA HAS A GREAT SWAY OVER
NOT ONLY ELECTED OFFICIALS, BUT
THE PEOPLE THAT VOTE IN
REPUBLICAN PARTY PRIMARIES.
REMEMBER IN A STATE LIKE TEXAS,
OWNING A GUN, A RIFLE OR A
HANDGUN, IS PART OF OUR HISTORY.
IT'S IN OUR DNA.
WE'RE VERY INDEPENDENT PEOPLE.
AND MAKE NO MISTAKE, I'M A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE SECOND
AMENDMENT.
IT'S THE COMMON SENSE REFORMS
THAT WE HEAR ABOUT FROM THE
PRESIDENT LAST NIGHT AND FROM
OTHERS THAT ALWAYS VEXED ME.
I WAS CON FOUNDED WHY WE
COULDN'T HAVE SIMPLE PROTECTIVE
MEASURES.
FOR EXAMPLE, OVER THE AGE OF 21.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED
ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN THE LAST
DECADE, PARTICULARLY IN TEXAS,
THE PEOPLE PERPETRATING THESE
CRIMES WERE 18, 19, AND HAVING
ACCESS TO WEAPONS.
SO WHY NOT RAISE THE AGE TO 21?
THERE'S NO RESTRICTION AGAINST
THAT.
WHAT HAPPENS IS IF YOU SUPPORT
THAT, IMMEDIATELY YOUR
CHARACTERIZED AS SOMEONE WHO IS
AGAINST THE SECOND AMENDMENT AT
ALL.
YOU HEAR THERIC LIKE HE'S
TRYING TO TAKE AWAY OUR GUNS OR
HE'S GOING TO LIMIT OUR ABILITY
TO ACCESS GUNS.
AND THAT'S OF COURSE NOT TRUE.
BUT THAT'S THE RHETORIC THAT'S
USED AND IT WORKS, AND
REPUBLICAN PARTY PRIMARY
POLITICS, PARTICULARLY IN RED
STATES LIKE TEXAS.
>> REYNA, YOU BROUGHT UP THE
EXAMPLE OF FLORIDA.
AFTER PARKLAND, THE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE MADE
PROGRESS ON GUN REFORM.
IS THIS A MOMENT WHERE THAT IS
NOT EVEN POSSIBLE IN OKLAHOMA
WHERE WE SAW THE TULSA SHOOTING,
OF COURSE IN TEXAS?
>> ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE, AGAIN, PRACTICAL
FOLKS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
UNDERSTAND THAT WE CAN NO LONGER
SIT BY AND REFLECT ON HOW THESE
THINGS ARE HAPPENING.
WE HAVE THE DATA TO SHOW US WHY
THESE THINGS ARE HAPPENING.
HOW PEOPLE ARE GETTING SAME-DAY
ACCESS TO WEAPONS THAT BELONG IN
THE HANDS OF MILITARY INSTEAD OF
CIVILIANS.
I GET IT, CONSERVATIVES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY DON'T WANT BANS, BUT
THEY CAN UNDERSTAND THERE ARE
THINGS WE CAN DO TO KEEP THESE
THINGS OUT OF THE HANDS OF
PEOPLE, SUCH AS THE NRA PUT IT,
WITH DANGEROUS BEHAVIORAL
ISSUES.
LET'S GET DOWN TO THE COMMON
DENOMINATOR.
THEY'RE ALL ABLE TO ACCESS
WEAPONS OF WAR.
WE'VE GOT TO PUT A STOP TO THAT.
THAT'S WHERE REPUBLICANS OUGHT
TO PUT IN AND DON'T SEND FORM
LETTER REPUBLICANS, DON'T SEND
THOSE TO YOUR FEDERAL LAWMAKERS.
SHARE WITH THEM PERSONAL
STORIES, LIKE I HAVE WHEN MY
DAUGHTER WAS GOING TO
KINDERGARTEN.
I FEARED BECAUSE I HAD HEARD
AFTER SANDY HILL THAT CHILDREN
WERE BEING DENIED THEM BY THEIR
PARENTS BECAUSE THEY WERE AFRAID
OF BEING SPOTTED DURING AN
ATTACK.
AS A MOM MY HEART HURTS FOR ALL
THESE CITIES BUT I REALIZE THAT
IT'S NO LONGER TIME TO SIT BY
AND HOPE THAT LAWMAKERS CAN DO
THE RIGHT THING.
WE NEED TO PUT THE PRESSURE ON
THEM AND THE GOOD NEWS IS SLOWLY
BUT SURELY, THE NRA AND GOP ARE
NO LONGER HAVE A CHOKEHOLD ON
ONE ANOTHER, AND THAT'S
HAPPENING IN REAL TIME.
SO WE NEED TO ENCOURAGE THAT TO
CONTINUE.
>> WE'